we can't erase every trace of evil from
the world
and small groups of killers have the
capacity to do great harm
that was the case before 9 11 and that
remains true today
and that's why we must remain vigilant
as threats emerge
at this moment the greatest threats come
from the middle east and north africa
where radical groups exploit grievances
for their own gain
and one of those groups is isil which
calls itself
the islamic state in a region that has
known so much bloodshed
these terrorists are unique in their
brutality
they execute captured prisoners they
kill children
they enslave rape and force women into
marriage
they threatened a religious minority
with genocide
and in acts of barbarism they took the
lives of two american journalists
jim foley and steven sotloff american
power can make a decisive difference
but we cannot do for iraqis what they
must do for themselves
nor can we take the place of arab
partners in securing
their region and that's why i've
insisted that additional u.s
action depended upon iraqis forming a
inclusive government which they have now
done in recent days
so tonight with a new iraqi government
in place
and following consultations with allies
abroad and congress at home
i can announce that america will lead a
broad coalition
to roll back this terrorist threat isil
is a terrorist organization
pure and simple and it has no vision
other than the slaughter of
all who stand in its way our objective
is clear
we will degrade and ultimately destroy
isil
through a comprehensive and sustained
counterterrorism strategy